france inter
léa c'est lui nicolas demorand le 7 9 et
avec léa salamé nous recevons ce matin
le président du parti les républicains
question réaction amis auditeurs au 01
45 24 7 milles et sur l'application de
france inter christian jacob bonjour
bonjour et merci d'être à notre micro ce
matin on le répète depuis dimanche soir
le résultat de ces législatives a été un
séisme politique qui débouche sur un
paysage parlementaire totalement inédit
trois blocs une majorité présidentielle
introuvable une percée historique du rn
et à gauche une huppe en force diriez
vous
christian jacob ce matin que le pays est
tout simplement ingouvernable
on effectivement dans un contexte comme
vous l'avez dit à juste titre qu'on n'a
jamais connu
la responsabilité entière et au
président de la et celle du président de
la république entière après we r oui oui
parce que moi je considère que c'était
un quinquennat un quinquennat pour rien
bien sûr il ya eu la crise du coc vide
et avec toutes les difficultés que cela
peut générer mais il ya eu l'avant
qu'ovide il y trois ans aucune réforme
de fait que des des choix tactiques mais
aucune aucune ligne politique
et puis et puis ensuite et bien à chaque
fois un président dans la tactique qui a
instrumentalisé les extrêmes il a
instrumentalisé marine le pen pour la
présidentielle sur le thème c'est moi ou
le chaos il a instrumentalisé
jean luc mélenchon sur le même sur le
même registre et se trouve effectivement
face à sète à cette difficulté
ingouvernable
c'est au président de la république de
trouver les réponses
c'est c'est lui qui a mis le pays dans
cette situation c'est lui qui porte la
responsabilité
c'est à lui de mettre quelque chose sur
la table s'il souhaite le faire à lui
avec vous sans vous nous nous avons une
ligne très très clair nous sommes dans
l'opposition nous avons fait campagne
dans l'opposition emmanuel macron parce
que ce quinquennat où il a été incapable
de porter aucune réforme où il ya une
gabegie sur la gestion des dépenses
publiques en début du début de
quinquennat a conduit le pays dans cette
situation c'est pour ça que nous sommes
dans l'opposition emmanuel macron nous
avons fait campagne sur ce registre et
nous y restons ça veut pas dire enfin
quand je dis dans l'opposition nous
l'avons fait pendant cinq ans en mettant
systématiquement des propositions sur la
table nous n'avons jamais été comme les
jean luc mélenchon et ses amis pour le
blocage des institutions pour la
révolution permanente nous avons jamais
été dans ce registre ni dans celui du du
front national pour qu'on comprenne bien
certains dans votre parti comme jean
françois copé comme christelle morançais
comme ce matin le maire de saint-etienne
vous appelle à faire un pacte de
gouvernement avec emmanuel macron vous
dites c'est non non et non pas de
gouvernement non parce que c'est pas les
combines la réponse ne sera pas dans les
combines dans les magouilles la dernière
fois le président de la république l'a
fait lorsqu'il a été chercher quelques
quelques âmes fragiles pour les faire
entrer dans son gouvernement quel a été
le résultat de l'arrivée d'edouard
philippe c'était une gestion calamiteuse
des finances publiques je pense que sans
doute qu'il détient le record de la plus
mauvaise gestion des dépenses publiques
pire que hollande c'était ça le début du
quinquennat donc ce n'est pas ça la
réponse n'est pas j'entends bien qu'un
certain nombre d'amis sont en attente de
poste ou de nomination peut-être c'est
que ça mais ça nous a coûté en tout cas
ce n'est pas la ligne que nous avons
retenu et ce n'est pas la ligne que je
défendrai parce que je considère qu' on
ne peut pas être dans une double
trahison de trahir nos électeurs ce
qu'ils nous ont fait confiance nous ont
pas élus pour siéger et pour être dans
le gouvernement des manuels mâcon ils
nous ont élus sur un projet qui était le
nôtre maintenant chargé emmanuel macron
de venir sur nos propositions
donc pas de contrat de gouvernement on
l'a entendu mais vous ferez du du cas
par cas vous voterez les textes du
gouvernement parfois oui parfois non
c'est sale c'est ça la ligne qu'on la
comprenne n'a baissé que le cas par cas
les textes viennent les uns après les
autres dans l'hémicycle à chaque fois
nous serons force de proposition
un travail étroit entre le groupe
parlementaire du sénat et le groupe
parlementaire de l'assemblée nationale
il y aura chaque fois des propositions
qui seront qui seront faites charge au
gouvernement et à sa majorité ou ce
qu'il en reste de les accepter ou pas
dans la ligne nous resterons sur la
ligne qui est la nôtre sur celle où nous
avons fait campagne c'est à dire on va
pas avoir dit quelque chose pendant deux
mois de campagne expliquer le contraire
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas de sens sans la
laisser le pays est ingouvernable
c'est ça mais ils disent vos amis vous
dites ils cherchent peut-être des postes
mais ce qu'ils vous disent c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le pays est ingouvernable
que face aux extrêmes ce sont les mots
de jean françois copé non mais attendez
si l'on était dans les airs au marché
que monsieur macron met des propositions
sur la table qui nous a conduits dans
cette situation c'est lui moi je vais
part je suis plus députés aujourd'hui
mais on ne va pas tous mes collègues qui
qui le sont on va pas avoir expliqué à
nos électeurs voilà notre projet est
maintenant qu'on est lui on va faire
autre chose on n'a pas vocation de
béquilles ou deux roues de secours oui
mais pendant la campagne présidentielle
vous aviez vous vous en souvenez
évidemment qualifié emmanuel macron
d'hommes photocopieuse vous aviez dit
qu'il plagie votre programme sur le
conditionnement du rsa une activité sur
la baisse des impôts de production sur
la relance du nucléaire sur la retraite
à 60 ans la retraite à 65 ans vous allez
l'empêcher de mettre tout ça en place
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas là la
cohérence je ne crois pas un instant
qu'il le fera est-ce que vous avez déjà
vu une fois emmanuel macron faire ce
qu'il avait dit moi pas tant qu'on est
dans les discours tout va bien
regardez sur la retrait la loi travail
il l'a fait il avait promis les est sa
fille l'a fait alors enfin on est très
loin lisf il a taxé les propriétaires
c'est totalement différent c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui paient la note
ce sont ceux qui ont investi parfois
toute une vie pour acheter pour acheter
un appartement pour acheter de la pierre
ou de la terre ceux là sont
effectivement dans la cible d'accord
mais si vous dit de là tout à l'heure
vous allez le voir à 10 heures à 10
heures vous avez rendez vous puisqu'il
reçoit les chefs de tous les partis
politiques c'est vous qui ouvrait le bal
a dit avec emmanuel macron vous allez
lui dire quoi vous allez lui dire si
vous faites la réf la retraite à 65 ans
si vous faites le rsa sous conditions si
vous faites un certain nombre de mesures
avec lesquelles on est d'accord on vous
suit c'est ça que vous allez lui dire
vous à lui dire quoi d'abord c'est lui
qui je pense a quelque chose à me dire
c'est lui qui a l'initiative
moi j'ai pas demandé recevoir et de
manière républicaine le président de la
république peut proposer un rendez-vous
bien évidemment je me rends mais je
pense que c'est une demande vous avez
quand même lui dit non mais je pense que
s'ils demandent à me voir c'est un j'ose
espérer que c'est parce que là quelque
chose à dire
donc je vais l'écouter bien entendu tout
à coup je pose la question s'est jamais
vous dit on fait la retraite de 60 à 65
ans ensemble est-ce que je peux compter
sur vous vous répondez quoi il dira
mettra les propositions que nous avons
fait depuis depuis toujours et nous
effectivement si ce projet est le nôtre
on va pas voter contre
à condition qu'il soit le nôtre donc
c'est soit le vote soit pas c'est ça
c'est ça va deux manières de le
compromis on est loin de l'allemande là
oui oui mais enfin j'ai pas une vocation
d'allemands non plus on a un système
politique qui est différent
l'élection
régime parlementaire vous avez 64
députés il 1 245 voix là et vous dit
soit vous face à s'aimer soi c'est mes
propositions se séparent mais non mais
attendez mais mais qui aime et qui a été
dans une arrogance d'une suffisance
permanent qui n'a eu qu'une idée de nous
détruire en permanence c'est bien le
président de la république qui a fait
monter les extrêmes c'est bien le
président de la république alors
maintenant il vient appelé au secours il
fallait qu'ils pensent avant aussi mais
là vous jouez votre position de pivot en
fait non moi je suis j'ai c'est d'être
pragmatique et réaliste et de ne pas
tromper les électeurs
nous nous avons fait campagne sur un
thème nous avons 62 des plaisirs quand
même nous avons 62 députés oui la douce
et en temps on nous en annonce et 30 on
en a 62 bien évidemment je respirais
qu'on en ait davantage
mais la situation est celle là et je me
vois pas revenir devant les électeurs
qui nous ont fait confiance en disant
non non attendez finalement sera pas
vraiment se passer comme ça elisabeth
bornes ne peut-elle rester première
ministre c'est le choix du président de
la république
ce qui aurait été cohérent c'est
qu'après
les élections législatives vous savez
que
le premier ministre en france à une
double légitimité celle du président de
la république et le nomme et celle des
responsables devant le devant le
parlement compte tenu de la composition
du parlement pense qu'il aurait été
sacké que madame ben pardon des pauvres
dépose sa démission au président de la
république après charges au président la
république de la renommée ou pas mais ça
relève de son choix c'est pas nous qui
nommons les ministres mais appelez vous
ce matin la nomination à ce poste d'une
personnalité qui serait issu de la
droite comme catherine vautrin par
exemple n'ont coûté chasser au président
de la république de décider ça c'est la
manip c'est les combines c'est les
magouilles
ça on a vu ce que ça a donné pendant
cinq ans on a vu le résultat
sur la gestion des finances publiques on
a vu le résultat en matière de sécurité
on a vu le résultat sur la politique
économique et qui a été menée donc ça on
en est pas oui on a vu les résultats de
votre parti aussi aux élections
législatives christian jacob et à la
présidentielle désormais ça peut sembler
stupéfiants le rassemblement national à
plus de députés que vous
comment vous réagissez à ça bah écoutez
c'est le choix des électeurs jeudi le
choix d'abord président de la république
c'était
celui d' instrumentaliser les extrêmes
nous nous avons été pris dans cet étau
et nous n'avons pas eu la bonne réaction
vous savez quand on perd une élection
c'est pas par hasard
si on la perd c'est qu'on n'a pas été
bon quand on la gagne on gagne on peut
gagner par hasard on peut gagner sur un
poids de coups de poker quand on perd
c'est qu'on n'a pas été bons et on a au
mois de décembre six mois avant
l'élection présidentielle
notre candidate était à 19 % dans les
sondages s'était même la seule qui
avaient des sondages lui permettait de
pouvoir bat emmanuel macron et ensuite
collectivement on n'a pas su desserrer
l'étau entre le rassemblement national
et emmanuel macron quoi la faute à la
caravane candidate la fota au manque de
soutien de partis la faute à quoi non
c'est toujours collectif vous savez dans
ce genre de choses toujours facile de
désigner tel ou tel la réalité c'est
collectivement
voilà on n'a pas su trouver l'espace
alors après on peut se trouver un
certain excuses d'ailleurs d'eau dont
certaines sont en sont réels le contexte
de gare en ukraine la sortie du coc vide
mais la réalité c'est qu'on a on n'a pas
été compris nos électeurs on n'a pas été
identifié les électeurs justement ce qui
explique en partie cette percée du rnc
l'effondrement du front républicain
brice teinturier nous disait hier
que les transferts de voix des électeurs
aient l'air vers le rn ont été bien plus
important que dans les scrutins
précédents la frontière entre la droite
traditionnelle et le rn s'effrite
toujours plus c'est un constat si j'ose
dire que vous constatez et que vous
admettez que ça se passe aussi par là
bas ce qui sépare les yeux ce qui s'est
passé aussi et beaucoup celle les
transferts au delà de ce que peuvent
dire les leaders mais on le voit
électoralement les transferts d
électeurs de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite et inversement
d'ailleurs c'est le même programme
économique si vous regardez le programme
économique de marine le pen ou de jean
luc mélenchon c'est rigoureusement le
même
dossier transfert d wade chez vous on
voit bien nommé bien évidemment mais
enfin moi je les bus dans ma
circonscription et on le voit partout en
france il ya eu un transfert
parce que leur programme économique est
le même c'est un programme qui n'a rien
de sérieux
mais qui a qui a séduit au moment ils
étaient prononcées il faut le
reconnaître le reconnaître sans nom
expliqué aujourd'hui qu'on revient à la
retraite à 60 ans fin c'est se moquer du
monde c'est se moquer du monde et on
peut pas dire ça et dire qu'on va
augmenter les pensions ou arrêter de
prendre les gens pour des imbéciles
si on veut effectivement est ce que nous
souhaitons relever les pensions de
retraite ça peut être ça ne peut se
faire qu'avec un allongement de la durée
de cotisation et christian jacob encore
une question depuis dimanche soir on
entend certains ministres macro nist
certains députés macro nist dire il va
falloir travailler avec leur assemblée
nationale il va falloir
s'ouvrir aura son nom nationale il faut
pour avoir la majorité on n'exclut pas
et chercher les voies du rassemblement
national ça vous semble normal ou où est
ce qu'ils sont en train de passer une
ligne rouge c'est blue sont les lignes
avec la macro ni un
ce sera à eux de prendre leurs
responsabilités nous nous avons été mais
sa part d'ombré poser la question ça
vous choque ou ça vous choque pas qu'il
dise on va aller chercher toutes les
voies possibles pour avoir des majorités
même le rassemblement national écoutez
tout on l'a vu avec emmanuel macron
toutes les combines sont bonnes il a
jamais a renoncé à rien il a toujours
été que dans la tactique d'ailleurs
reconnaissent en lui un certain talent
tacticien en revanche sur la vision
politique regarder sur le nucléaire il
faut diminuer le nucléaire passer la
part du nucléaire de 75 % à 50 % de
notre énergie pour fermer 14 réacteurs
ensuite il faut relancer il faut
relancer le nucléaire on s'oppose aux
biocarburants maintenant faut développer
les biocarburants encore me dire il ya
eu il ya huit semaines dire il ya deux
mois pour lui résidentiel c'est le il
épreuve c'est le front républicain c'est
moi ou le front républicain il faut
faire barrage à marine le pen et ensuite
dire on n'exclut pas d'aller chercher
leur voix il est prêt à tout
allez on filtre standard où nous attend
laurent laurent bonjour
je vous en prie on vous écoute ben comme
beaucoup d'électeurs de droite je vote
plus républicain et je voulais juste
dire à monsieur jacob qu'on est nombreux
à préférer la droite qui sert comme
monsieur le maire et darmanin à la
droite qui se sert et se nourrit sur la
bête monsieur ciotti et tous les
apparatchiks du parti donc anciens
électeurs elle est repassée du côté lrm
merci pour cette intervention laurent
que je transmets à christian jacob il ya
un certain nombre d'auditeurs sur cette
ligne ce matin aux standards christian
jacob dû coûter près des élus
d'apparatchiks eric ciotti s'est fait
élire élire sur sur son nom vous faites
référence à d'autres comme bruno le
maire ou edouard philippe vous donne
juste si vous êtes et si réellement vous
avez été le seul un électeur de droite
la gestion des finances publiques loyers
sur les trois premières années du
quinquennat on a été sur une
augmentation de 2,6 pour cent par an des
dépenses publiques avant sous françois
hollande qui dans ma bouche tu es
vraiment pas une référence on était à
1,4 c'est à dire que l'arrivée d'edouard
philippe et emmanuel macron on a doublé
le niveau d'augmentation des dépenses
publiques et cela avant la crise du coc
vite bien entendu après le coït c'est
autre chose donc écouter on a les élus
qui sont élus aujourd'hui député je le
dis d'autant plus facilement que je
n'étais pas moi même candidat s'est
amarrée élections l'ont été sur leur nom
et avec la confiance dans un retour au
standard où nous attend andreas bonjour
bonjour vous êtes allemand et on me dit
que vous vivez en france depuis 30 ans
et on vous écoute merci je viens lyon
est donc effectif on je suis un long et
ça fait trente ans que je vis en france
et parfois je suis quand même très
étonné de la réaction de certains hommes
et femmes politiques en france contient
monsieur jacob qui dit que c'est son
programme qui doit être quelque part
c'est son programme que le président ne
leur explique doivent adopter
il assez enfin les républicains ils ont
fait 4 % aux élections présidentielles
donc pour moi c'est quand même
ahurissant
d'imposer maintenant le programme des
républicains en france et quand on parle
consensus la raison et que vous avez
aujourd'hui mais si jacob avec
républicains pour justement construire
un consensus peut-être pas tout à fait à
l'allemande mais un tout et qu'ils que
dans ce sens là c'est quand même très
important et je hais je pense que c'est
une responsabilité que vous avez pour
les français et pour la france et pas
uniquement pour les républicains et pour
les électeurs des républicains voilà
merci andreas invitation à créer du
consensus
voilà ce que nous dit andreas close nous
dit la même chose sur l'application
christian jacob ne peut-il pas se
comporter en politique responsable et
faire comme les responsables allemands
qui sont capables de travailler ensemble
christian jacob réponses d'abord les
comme je le disais tout à l'heure notre
système électoral n'a rien à voir avec
celui qui existe en allemagne en
allemagne d'abord ils sont dans un
régime parlementaire avec les
collectivités notamment les länder qui
ont un pouvoir très important le le
chancelier ne peut pas prendre une
position sans venir consulter
systématiquement le parlement quand mois
pour avoir suivi beaucoup de
négociations européennes voyaient les
allers retours à chaque fois du
chancelier un moment de chancelier
allemand bloque les choses en disant je
dois aller consulter le goût de nos
stades et les responsables politiques en
france mais la situation le jeu des
partis là c'est sûr le joué par oui mais
bien sûr mais simplement le jeu des
partis ne tombe pas du ciel c'est parce
qu'il ya une cohérence institutionnelle
qui est différente qui est différent en
france et mais jamais le président de la
république n'a considéré à aucun moment
l'opposition ça n'était que mépris et
arrogance moi je n'ai jamais alors été
consulté par le président de la
république sur quoi que ce soit sauf sur
une pseudo réformes constitutionnelles
qu'il n'a jamais fait donc à ce que
c'est lui qui veut nous rencontrer donc
peut-être qu'il a quelque chose
d'important à nous dire on va voir je
l'écoutais un mot sur nicolas sarkozy
beaucoup de leaders de votre parti ont
dit leur déception leur tristesse devant
ce qu'ils appellent la trahison nicolas
sarkozy pour votre famille politique
pendant la présidentielle et puis
pendant les législatives notamment quand
il a reçu
l'opposante à brigitte kuster qui avait
été proche de lui et l'opposante macro
nist et il abrite qu stark a dit j'ai
honte pour lui devant une telle trahison
vous parlez aussi vos de trahison
nicolas sarkozy dont j'ai des
relations différents fin ancien ours qui
est le cas de brigitte kuster
séminaire beaucoup de d amertume et ce
que je comprends parce qu'elle était la
présidente du comité de soutien de
nicolas sarkozy et elle a été blessée
elle a très mal vécu je pense que
personne n'aurait bien vécu au delà de
ce mois j'ai une immense respect pour
nicolas sarkozy pour le quinquennat qui
était le sien je pense que c'était un
bon quinquennat je pense qu'il était un
bon président pour la pour la france et
ensuite bon j'ai des liens de défections
et d'amitié avec lui maintenant on l'a
vu dans les discussions politiques qui
nous anime aujourd'hui nous sommes sur
des visions différentes ou alors
le rassemblement national fort de ses 89
députés réclament la commission des
finances de l'assemblée la nuque réclame
aussi cette commission qu'en pensez-vous
christian jacob acquis doit-elle revenir
à ceux qui seront élus vous savez on est
dans une démocratie
et si l'une ou les non mais pour être
président de commission présente
commission s'est pas ont réclamé on
nomme
il ya la commission des finances grâce à
la réforme qui avaient été portées
d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy fait qu'elle
revient à un groupe d'opposition et donc
nous nous aurons aussi un candidat la
commission des finances après ce sont
les les députés de la commission des
finances qui élisent leur président la
première réunion du conseil national de
la refondation devait avoir lieu demain
mais elle a été annulée pensez vous que
ce projet sera enterré christian jacob
ou que c'était une bonne idée d'un
gadget total un outil de cooman plus
encore une phrase annoncé par le
président de la république qui ne fera
pas comme à chaque fois mais mais là
pour le coup il a raison de ne pas le
faire ce truc était ridicule
christian jacob s'est peut-être votre
dernière matinale ce matin peut-être
parce que vous ne vous êtes pas
représentée à la députation vous allez
quitter la présidence du parti les
républicains vous allez travailler dans
le privé vous allez faire quoi demain
après les vacances je vais d'abord
prendre des vacances
d'abord prendre des vacances
m'occuper de ma famille et puis après
oui je reprendrai une une activité sans
doute professionnelle mais pour le
moment où j'en suis pas remplacés goûtez
moi j'ai convoqué à l'issue de ces de
ces élections législatives par exemple
dans la région
rhône alpes il a une fille il a fait
très fort ce vous faites très fort est
ce que laurent wauquiez s'impose
naturellement à après vous mais moi je
vais arrêter là tout dans quelques jours
ensuite notre processus électoral fait
que les élections ont lieu en octobre ou
début début novembre
j'ai toujours considéré que le laurent
wauquiez avait tout toutes les qualités
pour
pour reprendre la présidence du parti
maintenant c'est un choix d'abord un
choix personnel pour lui ce qu'il est
candidat ou pas ensuite ce sera le choix
de nos de nos militants mais si la
question est sur le fait est-ce qu'il a
toutes les qualités oui les hommes parce
que pour vous il a l'expérience
de gestion de grandes collectivités
il a une expérience ministérielle
il l'a déjà dirigé le parti donc alors
après il ya aussi dieu merci nous avons
c'est de la ressource il ya aussi
d'autres gens qui ont qui ont beaucoup
de qualités vous touchez pas parce que
là si je commence à les citer que j'en
oublie ah bon mais la nouvelle
génération oui oui bien sûr bah écoutez
je pense les avoir largement aidé et
soutenu toute cette équipe de jeunes
j'ai eu à coeur en arrivant à la
présidence du mouvement de leurs leur
confier beaucoup de beaucoup de
responsabilités et ils l'ont fait pour
beaucoup d'entre eux avec beaucoup de
talent merci président en fuite et
laurent vous trouvez voilà merci
président jacob puisqu'on peut vous
appeler comme ça encore pendant quelques
mois en fût deux ans christian jacob au
micro d'inter ce matin merci encore